I love how they're all biting from my
love and attention and I have to do
nothing hi my name is Joyce and I am 23
years old and I'm for most of my life I
really didn't have any type of love life
I was too hot for the people that's why
I didn't read my horoscope though before
this and it said I need to be open for
expansion hi my name is Quan and I do
catering Hey
I'm Daniel and I'm a dancer either my
name is Jonas and I'm a lifeguard some
people are like you can get their energy
from how they text like domination
points or emojis or it's like really
flat nothing comes out hello everyone
welcome to the group chat first question
describe your perfect day in three
emojis okay that's cute I just don't
know where the mo juice is that I'm
looking for are okay so Jonas yes he
likes to drink he likes coffee damn
y'all he likes to party and he likes to
dance okay and one likes to go out play
video games and eat I'm not gonna lie I
like watching people play video games
because I'm weird
what's your astrological sign and do you
think it's accurate to you yes this is
what I need the sake I'm tired of these
water signs coming into my life and I'm
not gonna say my sign cuz everybody gets
on Gemini's Leo Aries Jonas come on
what's your time he might be a water
sign a few things so damn long
probably a Pisces he smelt
I knew it Jonas is a Pisces can I tell
ha ha I'm really talking about so I'm
like I'm trying to tell us how these
dates are you put his feet up in the air
I'm just gonna put heart emojis next to
all their feeds how someone laughs you
shoes do it yes the next question is
what is your worst pick-up line is the
classic I don't know bad are you Wow
we're almost at the end of round one
Black Panther or kill monger I can go on
on B - yeah I know like this is the
you're asking a Marvel nerd yeah outfit
kill monger because I feel like kill
monger really represents what African
Americans feel like being in a country
that you know it's an originated to them
this is the Make It or Break It moment
so Daniels a Black Panther Jonas said
violence is never the answer to the
larger problem black panther along with
the king but Juan said as a Marvel geek
I can tell the character of kill monger
has a great depth and its arc really
involves two out in comparison the black
panther oh man I got a love
five minutes okay now wicking jail
there's a lot at stake here I didn't
think I would really take this here like
it's so invested but I'm invested moment
you know what I'm gonna keep down y'all
goes between Juan and Jonas Jonas is
sweet
Jonas is a Pisces I'm an optimist
yeah and that was romantic so you know
let's hope for the best and one seems
fun - they're really like that kill
monger mommy he said exactly what I
needed to hear anyone's video games he's
gonna walk out the door to bring you joy
so intense
oh nice he's fine
no this this one you're fine you're hot
oh my god thank you I guess for the
opportunity at least and it was fun I
mean I had a little fun really nice
shoes says welcome to round two private
mode what's been the hardest part about
dating more faster faster I got you
if we only have five minutes and you're
taking this long okay he wrote a
paragraph never mind
a happiness biggest part is there's no
communication there's nothing there's
nothing Korean about ask her what's her
idea
I just stay active and party but also
chill dates are great too that just
explains what describes me pretty well
[Music]
told me that we should go out sometime
then and because we have so much in
common okay okay all right all right
yeah absolutely everywhere so you know
this body I twerk in the club he
probably does like ballet or something
you like work yo
so third will say choice and Jonas
honestly that's cute might just pick him
for that look who's around - what's one
of your most recent happy memories and
what you to say sentences genocide hike
- listen she and watch the sunset while
she said my happiest memory was watching
with his sister graduate from middle
school oh I already got separation
anxiety from Joy's text we ain't playing
games honey oh I'm gonna throw a little
bit flirtiness oh so he just sent me a
text you bring out the romantic side of
me
oh boy wants to play ask her if she has
any tattoos see I told you I don't man
you you've got this I don't but I want
some oh my god I'm putting I would love
to see your tattoo right sure Roger
Roger
oh then y'all I know that we would just
go out and dance oi sweaty he's gonna
kiss the nape of my neck I'm gonna wear
that red dress and he's gonna say choice
there's no woman more beautiful than you
or I could be with Jonas and Jonas is
something like soft and sweet ache me
hiking which I'll hate the whole time
cuz I hate hiking but I'll pretend like
I'm cute because you know I want him to
like me joy seems really cool very
expressive like down-to-earth but also
like willing to have fun and
have adventure but also stay inside but
know what's important in life to you you
know what Jonas was a guy that I was
gonna eliminate the first time but he's
so a nerd
let me go get this Pisces destroy his
life and make him write sad songs about
me look at this I just wanna say I
thought we were gonna bring joy together
but you know it's fine it's fine
I'll find love oh this is this is the
nervous part it's now like good nervous
[Laughter]
that was nerve-racking that was very
intense
Jenny one connection is very hard to
find in LA and you just want to find
that person to share all of the memories
with but you know okay